Hello everybody my name is Markiplier!
And welcome back to Subnautica.
Now I was trying to make this video already.
In fact, I recorded a whole bunch and I know exactly what I'm gonna show you guys.
But then my computer just blew up!
The recording was lost to the ethos, gone forever...
And now I have to do it again.
But the good news is, I know exactly what to show you.
Because you may be asking me from your
comfortable chair in your comfortable
home, "why aren't I building my own home on
my new island that I just discovered?" and
I would ask you in return *suspense* which island
should I build it upon? *Ecstatic* ( MARK WHY YOU BE SNEAKY!?)That's right! The
worst kept secret in all of Subnautica!
*in Deep Sexy Talk* I found another island *Normal Marki talk* and literally
there's another island and its not a
floating island and I'll show it to you in
a little bit but I gotta get through the new
names on the list here. So Colby Stone
said, "Mark you need to make a farming tray
from the island you should be able to scan
them and you can put them in your bases
which is good for getting food in the
future" so, Colby Ston your on *Mark chuckles at his own wordsmithing* you're on a locker
and then Santo's Gomez "Be
careful because this creature can open
gates in the ocean that can teleport you
back to the beginning." Now I don't know
what Santos is talking about but it sounds
horrifying and I don't want to run into
that creature. *Muttering Slightly* might be the sea Emperor. *normal*
and then *Mark says Colon instead of Colin* Stenniskus or "colon's,
Colin *you got it, Mark* Stan. Colin.. *regretful* Colon, oh God, what have I do... I'm so sorry Colin. Colin Stenniskus said
"wait until he runs into sea dragon
leviathan" and that doesn't sound good at all!
*growing intensity* Is that the creature that can open
gates and teleport me back to the
beginning of the game?!!!
*GASP*
Cus that doesn't sound good at all! So anyway thank you
guys so much for commenting and NOW I'm
going to get to the next place that I
need to go but I need my seamoth to do it I
don't know why I left it behind! HELLO BABY! Can
I get in you? PLEEEEAAAAASE?
AAAND thank you! OK. But there's another thing
also that I found and I'm really
disappointed that *markistutter* my recording doesn't
break all that often but when it does
it's always when I find the coolest
things because I went back *interrupts himself*
Let me just breach the surface here for a little bit HAAA BOOSHKY! AAAAH BOOSK! *back to normal Mark* So I went back to my, my little uh life pod there,
whatever you want to call it, and I
actually have the welder now, so I
repaired it and when I repaired it there
was another device in there that I had
not seen before and I think they added
in an update to the game and yous guys
are going to see it's no longer smoking
and dying in there! In fact it's actually
really interesting because this THING
has been drifting. It's literally been
drifting across the ocean because it
didn't used to be above the Kelp Forest.
It did not! It used to be on its own,
in a lovely place! Not here! But now it is
oddly out of place. But anyway that's not
the point. The point is I can see
everything from here and this is the
direction of the new island! But we're gonna get to that!
So I went in here and there was this thing
called a communications relay, and when I
opened it *Marki Pause* or when I clicked on it, there
was a weird message that said I had been
staying too long in the midnight reef or
something like that? It was really weird
and I don't know why someone would be
talking to me
But it got me thinking... Why am I the only
survivor of that massive, giant, GIANT, ship? Enormous
ship, it's HUGE. God dammit why can't I stay on
top of this thing? It's.. huge! But this
thing is freakin' huge.  WHOA WHAT THE HELL?
Whoa!
Whoa!!
WHOA!!!
EASY THERE!
WHAT THE HELL?
*Stunned Silence*
OK THEN?!
OH GOD! I didn't mean to do that! AUGH!
Oh Jesus I'm just tipping it overboard every time I go on the *markisound* Oh man...
There we go!!!
Well THAT was bizarre! I don't think the thing wants me to
think too much about the conspiracy
theories about this but *back on track!* why am I the
only survivor? On the only life pod... of
that ship? Literally! I'm the only survivor!
Even before it exploded, Karen said
that there were no life readings on that
ship or there were scattered life
readings but those were the aliens on
there... So what happened? Why am I the only
one and why is there no one else
anywhere around here? It's a good question,
right? One to think about. AND..! as I was
exploring near this island which we're gonna head
to right now, there was another
interesting detail that I found, and it was that
there are a lot more wreckages around
the map then I thought there was. If you
know *um* when I went out of the mushroom
caves early on in my series and I can't
believe I've been doing about 20 episodes of this, I
never imagined that I'd be playing this
game for this long but there's so many
cool things because whenever I go out
into the ocean here  *Marki Sound* whenever I drift,
whenever I see, whenever I explore a new
area now that I can go deeper I can
actually see all the areas that I'm *Marki Stutter*
going to, I find new things. Constantly!
Nonstop! I find new things because I'm
actually able to go down into the depths
like deeper, and this isn't even deep, but
I'm able to go down
way, way, way, WAY down...
HI SANCHO, how you doing? But I'm able to
go so far down that I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure if I continually explore, and
I've got a map pulled up with the game
here, I can actually see different areas.
There's like inert lava *thinking* pits or lava whatever
you want to call them there's inert lava
places and these *realization* OH YEA, THESE THINGS!
The floating islands! these giant bulbous
things are actually what are keeping the
island over on the other side of the map UP! So
it's *Marki Stutter* it's bizarre because that's over there
but these are over here and
there's a whole bunch of them there's a *thinking* there's
literally TONS of these floating... AND
HERE! YEA THIS WAS IT! THIS! THIS COOL THING! YEA THIS WAS A THING! OH IT'S SO COOL!
*Glad to see you excited Mark but take a breath, your gonna hurt yourself with the excitement!*
I already explored it because there's
nothing inside there so there's nothing really to
get but the fact that this piece of reckshud *corrects*
wreckage got blown out from the Aurora
*Markiplier takes a deep breath as the distant sounds of a horrifying monster can be heard*
*in deep sultry voice* Hello...?
got blown out from the Aurora and landed
perfectly on these two floating islands.
*Pause* And that's amazing! That's like really amazing!
I mean I know the developers put it
there! I'm not an idiot but, that's just
really really cool! It's just cool to have
that kind of detail in there the fact *strange noise* What is that? *noise intensifies* *Mark totally doesn't get scared because he's a Manly Man* OK?
WELL! I forgot that I was in the middle of the ocean
and it turned to god damn night, didn't it? OK
I've lost my bearings and I don't know
where I am! Am I going up? I hope da *nervous laughter* I hope I am... OOOK..
So we're gonna, Yea it turned to night. GOD DAMMIT
Why does it always gotta be night?
OK but I'm getting close. See, as soon as
I can see where the Aurora is *sees the island* OH THERE IT IS!!
I DON'T EVEN HAVE TO SHOW YOU! I don't even have to get
my bearings! So this is what I'm talking
about. There is.. a completely different
island and I don't know how I missed
these things, they're so obvious! This thing is HUGE!
It's annoy-it's jutting out from the
thing but if you go too far away from it
you won't see it. But THIS... It's so cool.
ITS SO COOL! It's just and thi-this this one's even
different because it's not a floating
island. This is literally just land jutting up.
So it's like a island in the traditional
sense that we'd find on earth here so
it's a guess it's not that special but
it's special to me because it's so weird.
And ON this island are the same little
skittering crabs that are found on the
Aurora, which makes me wonder why are
there land animals anywhere around here?
Like, what is the point of that? And that's
actually pretty convenient that the seamoth
actually casts a shadow like that. SO, in here I actually made a terrible
error and i'm glad you guys didn't see.
The only thing I like about this thing
crashing is: I made the stupidest
mistake that I could have possibly made when
I went in here, and this by itself is
cool because it's like an inside little cave
here, filled with rich detail and stuff. And you
can break these open and you get *messes up* shit!
That only had gold in it. But you can get
uranium out of some of these which is good, AND diamond! I
guess diamonds is good but who am I gonna give it
to? Gold, Gold.. *looks at spoopy cave and shudders* See these creeps me out
like I don't like it down here this *monster sounds come from outside, temporarily paralyzing Mark in Fear* OK!
I guess we're just gonna pretend like that
didn't happen! What is THAAAAT? What are you?!
What are you?!!! OH your tiny but your glowing!!! Oh you do back flips!!! He actually provides
light, that's so cool! I didn't even
notice that guy before because.. what I
did last time is I-I drowned *chuckles* I accidentally
came down here.. and I couldn't find the way
out.. and then I drowned like an embarrassing Son of a
bitch anyway that just leads back to
outside, so I don't need to go down there
right now, but if I can just get *doesn't get uranium* Ah. fek. faaaaaahk. frick. Frick Dude...! Fine then...
Gold... Nothing but gold. surrounded by gold and
diamonds I don't even know what the
diamonds are gonna be fo- *gets attacked by a crab* HEY! Stop that I'll kick your ass buddy,
from here to Tuesday!! Yea you better Run!!! *Marki Sounds*
Aaand ur #ded. BANK! gold. AH gold, gold, gold, who
needs it? *did I mention my name was Gold?*
URANIUM! There! So I got uranium and now
uranium can be used in the nuclear
reactor which is a research module th-or-um...
it's a scannable thing. I don't know if I
have it yet. I don't know if I ever got
it but I might have and that can provide
like unlimited power from a base which
is gonna be used when I do this and also
I noticed THIS... It looks like Pride Rock
from The Lion King that little outpost
right there and that little jut up. I think tha-uhleh I'm pretty
sure that's Pride Rock! Also there is a
path upwards to the top of this mountain
and-uh once again the reason I know all this is
because I recorded this episode already!
I did all this I had some really funny
jokes!
*in low voice* no I didn't I never have any funny jokes.
BUT
you can't believe that I had some funny
jokes when I was recording thi- OH YEA AND BIIIRDS!!!
IT'S GOT BIRDS!
Well I mean they're not really birds, they're like flaps of skin, like just
floating in the air it's actually really
disturbing. But we'll find more of them and I
can actually.. I can actually kill one I
think because when i sliced em- I haven't been able
able to kill one but, when I sliced it, like, I got spurts of
blood to come out of it which I'm
assuming means that it's dying and those
aren't just... tickle fluids coming out of it *said while laughing and crying* NOPE!
Ya, see I can't get one. they just fly
awa-they run away! why do they always
run away? Come BACK! COME BACK TO MEEE! Why won't they
love me? :'( *surprise hug* OH hello! Hi! That guy loves me too much!
OK, but also at the top of this mountain,
here, is.. a lovely view.. of... *drumroll please* the Aurora. And it
would have been great if I if I came
over here when this, like before the
Aurora blew up I would have loved, LOVED,
loved, loved, to see it from this vantage
point and there's no other way up to go
so I can't go any higher on this but I'm
gonna wait until daylight so that you
guys can see how cool this actually is
because you haven't been able to see
much of the island but now that it's going
to day, *in deep gravely voice* you guys are going to see. Maybe a can nab one of these
suckers... What are you doing in there?
*inhales* You wanna go bruh? You wanna go?
OK! Aaaand... it's now day. *sees the flippy floppy* Oh YOU!!
yes yes yes yes yes yes
Ah. Cmon. OH!!! *feels sad* oh... *saddening intensifies* Oh... I'm Sorry! *laughs at it's suffering* That's kinda sad now.
*while chuckling* Oh that's really sad.. Why did I do that?! OH IT WAS A BIRD!!! OH IT EVEN LOOKS LIKE A BIRD!!!
Oh now he is just spiraling into death. Oh the poor bastard. ok well that was sad, I
don't know why did that, but, anyway, alright then
ok so this is what I was talking about
this is super cool-YOU CAN EVEN SEE THE FISH!!!
YOU CAN EVEN SEE THE FISH!!! And there's
no way up to go I wish I could go higher to
the top of this mountain but I can't figure
out a way to do that unless I hop on one
of those jumpy bastards but *Marki JUMP! followed by Marki Scream*  And also the
gravity is just a little weird when you jump off of here
it doesn't quite-doesn't a hundred percent
work out the way its suppose to. *mutters* I need to go *sees giant monster* OH! Hi!
WOW! YOU ARE REAL! OK! I'm gonna get out here
thank you very much! I didn't know there
was one of those things over here- OH GOD!
it's a bitty bitch! Hello! Is this.. Ooh! Is this the home of
those things? Is this island their mating
ground? And I am gonna run into a bunch of baby
ones? Ok, so, with that being said I'm
gonna start exploring the different
areas in this new and exciting place because
if I go to the north no west-northwest
I'll get past the floating islands and
then I'll get into the mushroom forests
which was actually deeper than I could explore
before and I'll see a lot of really cool
things so I'll be right back when I get
to the new areas so see ya in a bit.
That is COOOOL! WHOA!!! That's a big one! What the heeeeell? HOLY CRAAAAAAP!!
OH MY GOD! Woah OK actually this is actually big. WHOA! That one's
massive. If that one had a few more
floaters on it could actually be like
the island floating above but you gotta
imagine that island is huge!
there's got to be a lot of floaters that
are working their butts off trying to
keep that off the ground.
OK, anyway! I'll be back! *five seconds later* But I mean..! OK! *Marki Sounds* I just have to
keep talking because this is so amazing this
is what I was talking about, like, I went on a huge
rant and I'm about to go on a huge rant again about
how cool this is: that I can go through
the ocean and finding new things
everywhere I go
literally I can go anywhere in this
ocean-Whoa, Hello! Hi! oh it's a giant pile
o' sand! I was-I was surprised by a giant pile of san-it looked like something that was a
giant pile of sand! Anyway! So I can go
through this ocean and I can be
surprised by Jeff-Hello! Wait?
*an underwater cricket chirps in the distance*
Wuz... OOOH!
COOL! Oh! OH these are-oh ok this one of the inert lava beds. OK
this is what it was talking about. There
were, like, inert lava streams-you can see, like, little bits of glowy lava
coming through. OK so that's cool.
we've officially reached where my last
recording stopped but I want to go in
here because there are just some
ridiculously cool things-Oh no wait! No this
isn't deep enough! Oh yeah I was deeper
than this. so there's gotta be.. um.. I know
there's gotta be something, that's gotta
to be like a drop-off connected to this
somewhere 'n going to FIND IT!I wonder if I-I believe
that I can cut these mushrooms Right?
I'm pretty sure I can. I don't know if there's any
use to them. There's a lot of items that you can get
in this game that don't actually have use yet, like, you can scavenge a lot of
things that don't actually combine with
everything else yet because they're
still working on the game. They're still
building the game inbutt- and they're updating
it all the time in between the last
episode and this one I think there
actually was another update although I
think it was just minor stuff but they're
constantly adding new stuff to the game
and I would- I'd be shocked to find out that
I actually found everything *sees drop* what is thiiiis? Well HELLO sudden drop-off into *sees a shiny* Whoa! HEEEEEY how's it going there?
It's ANOTHER one!
Oh cool!!
Oh cool- Whoa? Oh that's just salvage.. but there's
a lot of crap on the ground- What is that? That's an
upgrade module! Is that just a plain old upgrade
module? Cyclops Bridge Fragment? OK... Did I get some of these? No
apparently I got that already...
Eh, alright, whatever. OK... Cooool. Helloooo. Hiiii. How you doin'? Is there anything in this
one? 'Cus there seems to be a lot more boxes
Hello! Hi! Anybody home?
Cargo? Well at least this is more populated than
the other one.. Ok... cool. *hears monster outside* So quiet and dead I think
that's just a sandshark so I don't need to
worry about that. That's all broken..
Well that's no good.. That's all stopped up... For
having a whole bunch of boxes in here, it's just as
empty as the other ones!! There's nothing
in here! There's a whole lotta nothin!
Something in here?- Whoa, hello! *Gasp of amazingness* It's another Human!!!
[Karen] Warning, 30 seconds of Oxygen Remaining [Mark] Oh God I forgot! But look at that,
it's a picture of another human! I haven't even seen
another human in all of this! I was
wondering why I was the only one alone! Finally find a
picture of a human woman...! She's probably
dead, but... you know, that's interesting,
though. OK, so cool. I mean, I don't know if
there's anything important in these
wreckages just yet, but I do wanna find that cave
opening! So I'm gonna keep exploring . See ya in a bit.
Hellooooo. *hears the sound of a giant monster*
That's not a good sound! That's the opposite of a
good *sees a scary* AUUGH! That's not a good sound! OK! Alright! Running away! Oooh, I think it
spotted me! Ooooh this ain't good! Oooh it's not good, opposite of good! What is
that? what is that? what is that? Is it following me- *sees it*
Oooh. Uuh, what is this? Ooh. Oh. Hello! It's a hole in the ground! Oh God! *Marki sounds*
Oh God! Ooh.. Ok.... What the hell?
What the- OH GOD, WHY IS IT ALL BUMPY? *sounds of Marki Disgust* OH THIS FEELS WRONG! OH... OH MY GOD!!!
Where is this? is this the one? Oh.. Hello! what are you doing down there? Are you just falling to your- ?
Oh my God, they're just falling! Why did you come
down here? What is this? Ive never seen a biome like this..
*more sounds of Marki Disgust* it feels wrong! I don't like it! It's probably the leviathan breeding ground! OK, the only reason I'm going out is because I am out of
time for this episode and I want to make
sure that this episode actually recorded
before I go into any new territory
because I don't have to do it again! There are only so many
times I can be amazed by the same things! But that is... weird. The leviathan still out there? OK. So I have 51
percent power I'm pretty sure that's enough for my seamoth but.. wow.
Ok, anyway. So anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching, in the next episode I'm gonna
find out where this hole goes goes *very quitely* maybe it goes down to the center, who knows? *in normal outro mode* But thank you again and as always, I will see YOU, In the next video. BUH-BYE!!!
*CAPTIONS By: GoldTheWriter
Video (obviously) By Mr. Markiplier
Special Thanks to: Auto Generated Subtitles, for making me laugh A LOT
BYE!!! LOVE YOU MARK!